[Musique]
à 15 ans j'avais l' Pline et ma Pline
apporté du vent et le vent de sa
douceine ver mes désordres
d'enfant à 15 ans j'avais des rapaces
aux EAU des vieux et des grands je
savais leur faire la chasse de la pointe
de 15
ans à 15 ans c'est enelle que les belles
F ven battre de la la chandelle je
savais si bien les aimer à 15 ans
j'avais du panache et je n'écoutais que
ma voix à 15 ans faudrait que l'on sache
qu'on n'est jamais heureux qu'en
soit à 15 ans j'avais la moleste et
contradictoire souvent je vendais ce qui
se déteste je détestais ce qui se
vend à 15 ans j'aimis laaripaille le
corps des nimpes au cœur d'oiseau et
tout ce qui fait qu'on se taille la
meilleure repart du
morceau à 15 ans c'est en rant belle que
les belles de nuit son venait battre du
cine àes chandelles mais nul ne me
retenait à 15 ans c'est l'heure où les
reines s'apprêtent au festin des rois je
ne savais pas que la mienne commençait à
penser à
moi à 15 ans
elle a mis ses lèvres sur mes lèvres et
son corps dessous et j'ai bu comme un
bain de fièvre ce qui n'était qu'un bain
debout à 15 ans je ne chasserai c la
couru dans mes buissons et si j' cruvis
sa tendresse ce qu'elle cruverait mes
chansons à 15 ans c'est h rvelle que
tous mes amis sont venés tenir le col à
mes chandell qu'une autre flamme
consumait à 15 ans on croit qu'on
arrache l'amour comme une fleur d'un pe
à 15 s faudrait que l'on sache que
l'aurore se lève
tôt maintenant ma vie est petite et
petites aussi mes amours moi qui vivais
beaucoup trop
vite mes envies donnent sur la
cour maintenant qu'elle a mis la pâte
sur mes yeux mes rêves et mes fleurs il
faut bien que mon jeu s'abatte quand je
joue pique
elle coupe à cœur
maintenant c'est en randelle que mes
jours s'étirent dans nuit car elle a
volé mes chandell pour brûler mes
oiseaux de nuit maintenant il faut que
je cache l'amour dans mon cœur désarmé à
15 ans faudrait que l'on sache qu'une
femme ne perd
[Musique]
jamais